alright naturally I have to start this
week by talking about the horrific
attacks in Paris a few days ago sadly it
seems to me that these attacks are
becoming all too common these days and
each event continues in the path of
carnage and absolute savagery these
Islamic extremists want to impose on the
Western world yeah i did say islamic
extremists there i know that upset some
and makes the politically correct crowd
uncomfortable but unfortunately the more
we ignore the very set of ideas these
people tell us that they're using to
attack us the more we actually
strengthen them this is what my former
guests maajid nawaz told me he refers to
as the Voldemort effect JK Rowling
described this idea in the Harry Potter
books as quote fear of a name only
increases fear of a thing itself are
there any other ideas we should be
afraid of talking about I can't think of
any and I refuse to treat this one idea
differently we can't be afraid of scary
things especially in idea form because
that's how they will grow and morph
right in front of our eyes and of course
by saying these people who committed
these specific horrific acts were
Islamist extremists it obviously doesn't
condemn all Muslims if at this point you
can understand that distinction perhaps
there's a cat video out there better
suited for you than what we're doing
here I mentioned a couple weeks ago how
I'd like to move a bit away from talking
about the regressive left while I still
want to do that I feel like the
regressives are a lot like the Mafia the
more I try to get out the more they pull
me back in case in point the response by
many of the regressives immediately
after the attacks was to blame u.s.
foreign policy rationalizing we
ourselves are to blame for the people
who chose to murder over a hundred
innocent civilians after talking to my
last two guests Douglas Murray and
Faisal saeed al matar I've come to
believe this is an incredibly dangerous
and egotistical Lee driven view of the
world to the regressives everything
revolves around us people only do things
as a reaction to us so even though these
terrorists say they're doing this in the
name of religion and point to the actual
texts that prove it well according to
the regressives they just don't know
what they're talking about
that said as majin mentioned and as i've
been saying repeatedly two things can be
true at once it can be true that there
is an ideology out there a book written
by men a long time ago that gives plenty
of reasons to kill all infidels and at
the same time it can be true our Western
foreign policy created massive
instability in their part of the world
and perhaps if we left Saddam and power
Isis never would've arose every action
leads to consequences often unintended
ones sometimes America does good things
sometimes America does bad things but
thinking it's all about us all of the
time seems more like how a child would
think of the world then how an adult
would approach the problem of course
none of this will stop the regressives
from laying blame solely on America and
its allies the sim boldin about the
extremists themselves and those on the
far right I've been trying to have
discussions on this show so people can
see that there are others out there who
understand the nuance and complexity of
these very difficult issues we don't
have all the answers but we aren't
afraid to have the conversations that
most people won't touch let's pretend
for a second that all of the world's
issues were a hundred percent because of
America and we did exactly what ever it
is Isis would want us to do would that
make us any safer actually I'm pretty
sure we do the exact opposite by holding
the Western world in a perpetual hostage
crisis with the same people who have an
old text to justify just that final
thought on this I'm really not trying to
score cheap political points here by
constantly calling out their aggressive
I'm trying to lay out a case to show you
guys that the left is in real danger
because of the regressives misguided
head in the sand politically correct
brand of demagoguery at the end of the
day i blame these attacks on nobody
other than the sick twisted people who
committed these horrific acts of
violence at the same time i won't stop
speaking up against the misguided ideas
that will only bring about more of these
acts because we are afraid to look at
the whole picture and not just our
narrow myopic view of the world
you